I don't think that is being overly
optimistic or if it is,
I'm,
I'm right there.
And I think a lot of other people who
care about creativity,
creativity,
not just for the sake of art itself,
but creativity as a way of looking at
problems,
looking at human beings,
looking at the world from a number of
different angles.
At the same time,
I think that what we've seen from a lot
of Obama's political utterances that I
think is very resonant with people who
have sort of chosen the creative life
and who find inspiration for the
creative life is that there's not one
answer.
Many things are sometimes true at once.
You can be in the midst of contradiction
and not have that be a stopping point,
but rather be a weigh station on the
road forward.
We've heard a lot of that kind of
language from him and I think that
that's something certainly that great
literature tries to show us as well.
Um,
that,
you know,
for example,
to be American is not one thing to be
American is multi experiential,
multilingual.
Um,
it is,
it is many,
many,
many different aspects of the human
experience.
And that's really part of what makes
this,
in my opinion and incredibly interesting
country with a very,
very vibrant arts scene.
Uh,
it is that essence that is not one
thing.
And,
uh,
so I think that,
that,
that comfort with contradiction is
something that we've seen from the
president as well.
So I see that as,
you know,
fertile ground for the area.